what's going on there reject nation
lauren francesca who hasn't been on this
channel in a few years is now back with
me today yes she's back in l.a yes
follow her on social media yes actress
influencer model director producer
writer dancer uh philanthropist just
follow me real estate mogul
dog lover dog lover you're a follow we
are gonna watch today the movie encanto
that's right guys not marvel dc or star
wars john is uh getting surgery right
now that tooth thing that you guys were
making fun of him about well he's
getting that fix he's going to be out of
commission for a few days so i was like
time to catch up on some movies she's
been wanting to hang out and i said no
no no we don't hang out we collab and
now we're gonna watch sewer together
full length watch along where you sync
up with the time girlfriend contour
we'll be at our patreon page cover a
whole bunch of things over there as well
thank you all who have joined but if
you're not gonna follow us on patreon
the least you can do is leave a like
that would be very much appreciated and
then boys at prepper thank you so much
for helping us edit down these
highlights let's get to it i hear this
movie is a joy
[Music]
this candle
holds the miracle given to our family
your abuelo pedro and i were forced to
flee our home
oh
we could not escape the dangers
and your abuelo
thank god
i need blessed
with a refuge in which to live
oh that's what an encounter is the
miracle blessed each with a magic gift
to help us
and together our family's gifts
have made our new home
a paradise
wow
real estate
[Music]
whatever gift awaits will be just as
special
as you
cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the truth is
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh she doesn't have a gift oh no
you're deflecting
[Laughter]
they were just asking about the family
oh
that is so sad
that's so sad
i gave you the special since you're the
only mother god kid with no gift i call
it the nut special special since uh
you have no gift
if i was you i'll be really sad
i am just as special as the rest of my
family
all right guys where do i drop the wagon
maybe your gift is being in denial yeah
[Laughter]
damn all my hispanic friends have been
holding out on me look what they all do
that's what this movie's telling me
thank you oh it's nothing
a little sisterly advice if you weren't
always trying too hard you wouldn't be
in the way
it's called helping and i'm not in the
way you are
she reminds me so much of you lauren
thanks greg thank you
remember remember you have nothing
nothing to prove oh that's a good
message the best way for
some of us to help
is
to step aside
let the rest of the family do what they
do best
this is really sad
oh
if the gift ceremony doesn't go well
this time
tonight will be hard for us
i don't know what it's like to not be
gifted how do i identify with this
character
[Music]
[Laughter]
how do we how do we invest in this place
[ __ ] the pressure you could put on
here in this family
oh
no why oh god
[Music]
hey
i understand you
of course they can come
what he talks that is the coolest power
ever
oh man
wow
what
whoa
oh you lucky little kid
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
like doctor who we need a picture
everyone come come come come
please don't ask her to take it oh my
god
let her be in the picture
she's not in the picture on the picture
why isn't she in the picture i am
totally fine
i will stand on the side as you shine
[Music]
i can't hear what's broken
can't control the morning rain or a
hurricane
am i too late for
a miracle
no
no you have nothing to prove
[Laughter]
i'm glad we could meet up lauren so we
could just cry together
holy [ __ ] did you pick this one on
purpose
and we don't have tissues i am so sorry
oh no
when she gets cut why is this movie so
meaner
oh
no she's breaking everything this is a
breaking act too right now
[Music]
what is going on the tiles were falling
and there were cracks everywhere
and the candle almost went out oh show
me
what
oh she had a vision
there is nothing wrong with la casa
madrigal
the magic is strong and so are the
drinks
oh well who's in denial now
oh
what are you doing knowing how this
movie treats her she's gonna fall down
and break her neck
i need you
cracks in our casita
she believes her
oh
she believed her yeah
take the candle i will save the miracle
oh no
[Music]
wait
how do i save a mirror
i was like what is she doing
dolores says you're totally freaking out
any chance you maybe know something
about last night with the magic
[Laughter]
spoken to the guzmans about mariano's
proposal to isabella
dolores do we have a date
tonight
he wants five babies
wow
lisa if you know what's hurting the
magic and it gets worse because you
won't tell me what's wrong nothing's
wrong
wow
sorry that uh that snuck out there what
i meant was
am i finally platinum i take what i'm
handed i'll break what's demanded but
[Music]
[Music]
miranda write this sounds like a song
[Music]
this is awesome
[Music]
no mistakes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
amazing yeah i won't run to write that
it sounds like a lin-manuel song that's
good last night when you saw the cracks
i felt weak
oh
the magic is with the ring
i got chills
[Laughter]
start with bruno's tower find that
vision
that place is off limits for a reason
uh-oh the one non-magic person has to
save the magic people
your future awaits oh wow welcome to the
family my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh no
no
oh my goodness
she is brave
hurting the oh
oh no she can feel it
is that a bad thing that she's putting
the cracks back together it certainly
appears that way
[Music]
she's hurting the magic oh no
how did she do that
if he
had a vision about someone
what would it mean we don't talk about
bruno i know it's just
what a nightmare
what if you didn't understand what he
saw then you better figure it out
because it was coming for you
we don't talk about
why
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
no no
[Music]
oh that's the worst
[Music]
oh no
i
broke into bruno's tower i found his
last vision the family's in trouble the
magic is dying the house is breaking we
skipped his waiting and i think it's all
because of
me
[Music]
no boy no
the house is not breaking louise's gift
is not fading no one will know just act
normal no one has to know
listening girl uh-oh
[Laughter]
no stop the gossiping
[Music]
that's what a [ __ ] so fast
[Laughter]
man those rats know a lot huh they're
fast they know something they know
something
[Music]
that was nuts
[Music]
oh boy
it was like a horror experience for you
oh oh my goodness little girl
whoa
oh boy
you're very sweaty
oh no
that's good that's good
wait
have you been in here
patching the cracks all the patching is
done by hernando who is it i'm hernando
and i'm scared of nothing it's actually
me
i say my real gift was acting
[Music]
i look like him
i declare this definitely
oh
wow
that's so sad i had this vision the
night
that you didn't get your gift and i saw
the magic
in danger
i saw you
maybe she's the savior you wrecked my
vision cave which is a problem because i
need a big open space we'll find one
where this is my room
oh what
what if i show you something worse if i
see something that you don't like you're
gonna be all bruno makes bad things
happen oh he's creepy and his vision
killed my goldfish
it's the candle
the candle's getting brighter i i think
you're gonna help the candle how others
there's someone with you and you
get a fighter wait no no no no is that a
hug
oh
to make the candle bright you have to
embrace her embrace who oh almost there
almost there
i got
[Music]
[Laughter]
get
out
apologize for ruining my life
go on
oh my god it's not worth it let the
magic die oh my god
the only thing you have ever done for me
nothing is messed up you can still marry
that big dumb hulk i never wanted to
marry him i was doing it for the family
oh
wow
that is a very serious confession
wow
okay get over here bring it in
[Laughter]
i just made something unexpected
what else can i do wait bring it in
bring it in
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i wish i could do that with my sister i
know
they hit up jaby kawai right now
[Music]
yes
i don't know why you weren't giving a
gift but it is not an excuse for you to
hurt this family
no she doesn't get it
i will never be good enough for you no
matter how
hard i try no
that's not
you don't need to be you're the one that
doesn't care
you are the one breaking our home
the miracle is dying because of you
oh
[Music]
uh oh no no
just get the kid
[Music]
god i hope
oh
freaking bruno's okay
damn oh no
oh
oh
no
[Music]
[Music]
jesus christ
i was given a miracle
a second chance
and i was so afraid to lose it
that i lost sight of who our miracle was
for
i asked my parent for help
she said to me
[Music]
hey
hey yeah you got to have disney
it was me i was like go and she was like
she only wanted to help
i don't care what you think of me but if
you're too stubborn to to oh
i think it's
just your
a gift is you not some gift just you
a miracle is you okay so
we're gonna talk about
you take care of your mother when you
make her proud you write your own poetry
every night when you go to sleep and i'm
seizing the moment so would you wake up
and notice me
[Music]
i see you
i hear you
[Laughter]
before the
celebration what
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
it's a really beautiful message man yeah
that's a really beautiful message
[Music]
[Music]
yes she made the photo
wow
miranda i called it yeah
oh yeah yeah it was like the rap rhythm
style i was like this sounds a lot like
his flavor wrap i was more touching than
i expected it to be yeah wasn't the
animation it's so great it's amazing
it's so expressive
they really know how to utilize those
musical numbers just tell a wide variety
of styles that was beautiful wow i
thought it was like crazy i was like
pretty contained too there's they all
took this one little section but they
managed to do so much with it yeah it
was beautiful i just i didn't know i was
going to cry all night tonight thank you
for that yeah i think you needed it yeah
i think you need it you just cry you
deserved it yeah you earned this cry
tonight lord
like 20 minutes in at the very end i was
like this might be my new favorite
disney movie i think so
wouldn't blame you for feeling that way
yeah that was beautiful it was amazing
did she get a gift at the end did i
super that's her
her gift is her being herself oh
that's so beautiful or she's the
sorcerer supreme she's a witch
he's evil it's a warning time
[Laughter]
when you told me we're gonna watch like
a two-hour movie i was like oh my god
i've seen the batman three times this is
nothing
it's a walk in the park
yeah marvel trained us to see if there's
a post-credits scene for everything we
watch now yeah that's what i'm waiting
for yeah we're just thinking all right
guys
we're gonna keep it straight to the
point here because it's pretty late at
night
but uh
obviously laura what do you think lauren
tell the audience what you thought it
was best disney movie ever i laughed i
cried i learned about myself i want to
call myself
this changed my life changed my life i'm
quitting all social media focusing on
what's important right here right my
gifts don't matter
they mean nothing maybe nothing no
matter i'm good enough
yeah that has a really great message
about you know
funny some things we were talking about
beforehand about like self-worth and
i feel like you don't have to prove
yourself and not feeling it's like
there's a there's a weird correlation i
think you can make in life in a lot of
ways where you feel like you're
you can be determined at least from you
know still all the hispanic culture but
we're talking like a lot of american
culture especially that a lot of your
worth is determined by your career
success but like that's what it's about
what it's about is who you are as a
person like this is really a message
about unconditional love with your
family and such you're gonna make me cry
again i know it's a great message it's a
great it's a great message about feeling
like you don't have to try to prove
yourself to to anyone even your family
members that you are valuable enough as
a human being and i think that message
is so powerful and i didn't i kind of
saw him like the theme was stated early
on i'm like you know to prove yourself
here about like i know that thing was
stated early on but i expected to wrap
around such a powerful lesson for
everyone involved i thought it would
just be like for her
and it i like the i really like the
direction it took because it seemed like
it was gonna be
you know oh she would probably be the
one with the craziest gifts that would
be unlocked or something but it wasn't
about that her gift was
saving her la familia or el familia do
you speak spanish no but i think la
familia is correct la familia sounds
right yeah sounds right what was your
favorite song uh
wow there's so many i look i really like
the one that uh
maybe it was uh julieta when it was uh
it was like the it was the one where you
were like oh linwell miranda probably
didn't work at one yeah
yeah there was like dance moments in it
like i just wanted to dance the whole
movie i loved how expressive it was it
was so sweeping like obviously colorful
however it's like the way they i don't
even know how to quite put it into words
like they had amazing camera work here
and they did something
sometimes like psychedelic
the flowers were just amazing i loved it
it really seemed like hone in on like
latin culture the food the food i am so
hungry dude i am starving yeah i am like
so hungry and it looked really good even
though it was a cartoon i was wanting to
taste that yeah wow i want to go to your
house for dinner and i i just think the
way the story weaved was unexpected like
there were just a couple of predictable
things like it's like okay bruno's has
to be around or live somewhere but yeah
i didn't expect them to be just like
right there watching over the family
this whole time i thought it was really
cool they did with the uh with abuela
you know
um
like what are you're italian right yeah
italian i'm italian filipino so it's all
similar it's all similar it's the same
thing yeah it's the same thing same
thing
yeah
exactly
but uh i mean every
my whole life i grew up around
like
latin culture
even my fiance spanish you know and so
i've been exposed to a lot of this
but i think even in my i think filipino
culture and i think there's some parts
of italian culture too i think even
filipino culture you know you do have
that because there's such a hierarchy
with family a lot of the time and
especially when you're close with your
relatives it's like grandma top of the
chain
you know and then you can feel like your
whole family is determined by what your
grandma kind of thinks about everything
you know so i like that they have this
like matriarch yeah
figured they had this whole arc with the
with the grandma too that i thought was
insane yeah sad yeah when they they
within the first five minutes it was
like the the dad and mm-hmm it's just
really sad it was heartbreaking it was
really sounds like this was mean to our
main character let's keep putting her
down but i'm like i've been privy to
that
in a lot of
parts of the world so yeah and i think a
lot of us know what it's like to be that
family member yeah a lot of us know it's
like to be that whether it be family or
school or like i think there's a lot
that people could just identify with
um with with this mirabelle character
you know and uh and even like i like how
they i thought all the family members
had wonderful personalities like
everyone was very distinct yeah and the
even with the sister i thought that was
a nice surprise it's all relatable yeah
everything about it is relatable
but even with uh the sister is isabella
yeah right right the the one who's
perfect the one who's perfect yeah like
how
i love how that got put together or you
know like that is actually something
that weighs on her yeah that she's
perfect and she doesn't want to be with
a guy because she doesn't want to she
doesn't want to have [ __ ] but she has to
be perfect that's standard it's like
celebrities yeah it's like me you know
like everyone just looks at me and goes
perfect and you got everything greg you
do and i'm like i too and life's great
and i really have no pain internally so
i can't identify with anyone in this at
all because
i don't understand
the opposite of happiness
all this crying you were doing i was
like i guess i should try to cry so i
was like hurting myself physically
because that's the only way i could cry
anyway this bit's over
but yeah um
yeah and i like how the music really
told moved the story forward every time
or was also
like revelatory about the the characters
too and the dancing dancing dancing was
amazing i don't know who choreographed
it but they were like really trendy
dances and
i know if i used tik-tok i would imagine
a lot of this song to talk right about
now yeah all those dances look like we
should learn them i bet this movie i i
could see why this movie has been
developing quite a reputation
what what related rama was the daddy
that was crazy yeah that what was up
with him keep getting the beast stinks
was that is that did that have a meaning
yeah it's a big part of latin culture i
don't know
this is like one of the quirks about her
or something like that
i don't know but it seems like a lot of
people involved were of like the actual
race which is always cool to see honored
here and uh you can just feel like a lot
of spirit and love here and i like how i
never felt like the comedy
was undercutting dramatic or serious
moments sometimes you know especially
like an animated film you could feel
like they're like we gotta keep it funny
so just throwing some comedy here
but they really let certain scenes
breathe and feel like heavy and and
really sad you know really sad yeah this
is really sad i got scared a couple
times you freaked out one time she
knocked down her headphones
you could make for a fun edit here yeah
sorry about that
that's really scary damn
reaction laura would not survive
you're so scared i get into it i get
like really emotional
well i think that's what's cool is that
it's very
uh
perilous like you feel the peril yeah
very much so so
yeah man i mean i think this was a
beautiful film this was beautiful with a
great heart about it and a great lesson
for kids out there i feel even adults
can learn from this
movie yeah i'm going to be learning from
this
yeah i'm going to be journaling
[Laughter]
curious a whole new rebranding for i
want my lord yeah definitely definitely
there's a lot of lessons to be derived
from here yes uh guys thank you to
everyone who encouraged this um i'm just
catching up on movies that i've been
wanting to watch believe it or not
watch a little bit more than marvel dc
and star wars and no one's know i want
to watch one of these thank you lord for
being here i appreciate your authentic
authentic honest emotions
go follow her on social media
where do you where is the main place you
used to
everywhere just you you can since you're
on youtube already just go to my i want
my lauren channel or find me everywhere
i want my lauren if a social media
platform starts up lauren gets on top of
it yeah that's uh it's a real it's real
addiction you don't have to prove
anything anymore lord you're not good
enough my phone broke before i got here
so i'm just i'm
feeling like there's some weird message
in the universe right now i don't know
that's why you were so vulnerable then
today's reaction yeah
this has a meaning
i'm supposed to listen
to be in the present moment what what is
happening right now there's so much
stuff going on you have no idea
guys uh thank you so much for being here
and uh you can check us out catch us on
patreon we'll talk to you guys soon
you